and the reason we're all here is the
great
great
ruth [ __ ]
i always had it in my mind that i wanted
to be an actor from a very young age i
fell in love with film from a very young
age um
like uh people of my age uh the vhs was
how i felt
um and on friday nights my cousin and i
got six foot with three films each and
that was
our reason for living um
and it was just the extraordinary thing
of you know going into i mean no one no
no young child knows what that's like
but opening the door into your
blockbuster your drop burst or your
extra vision where we were in ireland um
and just
seeing this choice
laid out um
and
that was how i found i just i think i
fell in love with storytelling
and that was very much i wanted to be
part of that world i didn't quite know
maybe for a while it was acting i wanted
to do
but um i think i was labyrinth that i
saw for the first time and david bowie
coming down those stairs kristen i
thought
whatever he's doing that's what i want
to be doing um
and um
i don't think i'll ever reach those
dizzying heights but um i can always try
and um but i i was very shy and i didn't
really want to go to
you know sort of a saturday drama school
um
so i i think i waited out my teenage
years as many people do um
and i trained i got into um i actually
applied to go to trinity college dublin
to do the academic course the academic
drama course and i got into that but
then i found out that there was um
a practical training course and
it was within the umbrella of the
university so there weren't these
you know um enormous fees that were
associated with a lot of the drama
schools that i i were in england and i
just couldn't afford that so um and i
knew i wanted to study at trinity
because i knew they had a great
um program at the same rebecca center
within the within the the um
the university so i got in luckily and i
was very lucky because there's a class
of only 13 of us and
you know my fees were minimal they're
just like university fees and so that
was an excellent three-year training and
i was very lucky to get a job
in the abbey theater as soon as i left
college so
it sort of has progressed from there do
you think the formation in theater was
essential or did you have to like learn
new skills every time you shifted to a
new mode
for me it was because it gave me it gave
me confidence that's the best thing that
i mean ver gave me very many other
things but um
it gave me a confidence and it gave me a
work ethic which you is invaluable as an
actor um and
i think i mean i don't necessarily think
everyone needs to go to drama school but
i think you need to graft
um
but the great thing about the thing
about theatre is it teaches you about
just the the basics it teaches about
space
behind you in front of you you know it
teaches you about um space in terms of
other actors you know it teaches you
about
voice what you can do with your voice
you know and and um
it was never
um my um
i always i never thought and we were
never taught this in drama school that
we could only limit ourselves to
fear sure and i'm not saying that it's
limiting
but that um you can there are
transferable skills
um it's just that
it's just that we didn't have specific
camera training but you know these are
things you can learn on the job i very
much believe yeah
what
would you say may have been your biggest
roadblocks along the way um you could
either internally or or literally in the
field
i think other people's perceptions of me
that may have limited
me and i think i'm not alone in that
um i think that
um
not just as a person of color but as an
irish person of color people were very
how did that work
um
but funnily enough that never happened
in my own country you know i got to play
roles uh the first ever role i played
was alicia
in um
an adaptation by
michael west which was put on by annie
ryan who is a nation of chicago and who
moved to
um ireland um i got to play abigail in
the crucible at the abbey i got to play
pegin in playboy western world for druid
theaters so
i never found it to be limiting in in
ireland for whatever reasons i'm
i don't know if i'd have been afforded
the same opportunities elsewhere
um
i know that i mean
when i was fair when i was starting out
i think
someone said there was this article in
the newspaper once it said ruth nego
believes her heritage is holding her
back and that's like it's not my
heritage that's holding me back it's
other people's perceptions of what my
heritage is heritage means
that they think er that makes them it's
narrowing
the trajectory of what i'm capable of in
their own minds not what i am think i am
capable of and i think that troubled me
for
for a while but i do think things are
changing you know i do i do i genuinely
do
they they are um but i can say
anecdotally i was at a festival recently
and there was a panel of you know talent
to watch and there were three amazing or
four amazing talented people
uh
three of them were
30 and over up to you know mid to late
40s and one was 21.
and the 21 year old had been in three
major films by three blue chip you know
art house directors
and the others had been working steadily
but were just now breaking through and
the fact that she was a young white
woman and that they were three people of
color i don't think was lost on anyone
who is a person of color in this field
you know that there just
are certain perceptions that the young
white woman maybe didn't have to you
know kind of navigate before she got um
you know to to work with blue chip
directors and the others happily are
there now and and doing the same but
there are those roadblocks still
oh most definitely but also i think you
can't sort of
hijack anyone else's narrative and you
can also um project your narrative onto
someone else
and what i mean by that is i can't speak
for anyone else i can only speak for me
and you know i'm definitely not the 21
year old um
i'm 35 now and it feels like
all i can say is just it feels like that
there is some there's a conversation
happening now and there wasn't a
conversation when i was starting off and
that's very hard to do when you're you
know you have this work ethic and you're
itching to go and you can't even get
your foot in the door i mean and i think
that's all people want people just want
an opportunity
and that's the bottom line you know and
i think um
and i do i do i do i do sympathize and
empathize because i've been that you
know
um
that person you're thinking oh but
um unfortunately that has been the
reality there's nothing we can do about
that but what we can do
you know the lovely thing is is that um
loving
loving um was the first film to be shown
at the african-american museum in uh
washington
brilliant it was a huge privilege for us
a huge privilege for us and then
moonlight was the second it was the
night after
and that it was amazing i know i have i
haven't seen that yet and i can't wait
but and and coming home to the hotel
after we'd shown and seeing all those
guys and saying hi it was such a lovely
feeling because it felt like and we're
seeing each other in a circuit it felt
like it felt like something was
happening and that was very important
it's very important for me as a human
being but also as an actor but also it's
very important for
um
young people of color in this business
to see that happening
because
um
um it's it's just super important i've
always said like i've always been quite
astounded by
the idea that i didn't see that many
people who looked like me on television
when i was growing up and so to see
people and i'm always quite shocked at
my complacency about dash
and that's quite sad isn't it i think
that's really sad but i don't want young
people of color growing up now to feel
that same thing i want to do i want them
to go and
yeah
you know
um and i think that we have the
potential to do that but the thing is
that nothing is
we say this when we talk about our film
nothing is done and dusted
no conversation is finished so we can
never we can complacency is dangerous
because it assumes that
everything's fine now and it's not
but it doesn't mean that it's it's it's
not
we're not getting there you know there
is there is room for hope and that's
what mildred says in our film again and
again is hope be hopeful and we have the
capacity to be hopeful
and i think that but we must we must
always be having that conversation and
checking ourselves and thinking
you know um
it's very important for us to see
ourselves reflected because what it does
is it validates us and when we see
ourselves validated
it it it gives us something it gives us
um
a common humanity
that we can all share in
and it makes
society better because there's no one
left outside there's no one left behind
because when people left behind that get
lefty and that's when problems start
and i and it's also just not fair
yeah
no um
you know with any kind of terrible
rambler i'm sorry i am irish so
no i could swim in this it's amazing and
you know with any um intelligence and
block i suppose there's still luck you
and the crew from moonlight will be um
swimming in this pool of conversation
and uh acclaim throughout the season
it's two remarkable films um i do want
to talk about um your your television um
work a little bit before we shift to
loving which um i know
uh we all have questions about and
but you're on a show right now that's
quite popular called preacher we saw a
little clip
got some fans all right
um and i wanted to talk about your work
in in fantasy you also made a film or a
film came out this year warcraft uh
another fantasy project
um
talk about that spectrum you know of and
we're going to talk about biography with
with shirley and and with loving but
talk about just that working in the
fantasy realm where you really it's
almost no holds preachers is based on a
graphic novel series comic book um and
warcraft obviously on the on the video
game but you know within that there is
just this whole other realm that you can
explore and are it seems like maybe
that's a an interesting place for you
right now
oh most definitely i mean i love
preacher um it is a comic book i was
semi-familiar with because
uh i grew up with a lot of boys who were
very into comics and it was always lying
around and i was always sort of like
beguiled by this
fascinating strange thing but i was
always i remember reading i love comic
books and i love graphic um
novels because i love i love visual
media i love art and but i i was i don't
know if i only remember this
comic book called misty
and it was this really peculiar comic
book that was like from another time and
it was really it was for girls
um but it seemed like there's some sort
of subversive like it was for girls on
the cover and then you would open it up
and you was like wow this is like
not any like any for girls magazine i've
ever read
and i just love the macabreness of it
and i remember thinking you know girls
like the macabre too why can't we have
you know why can't we be have the same
sort of allowance to to like that um
and i think that you know i think that
in many ways the comic book world is is
is is also reflecting what's happening
as well you know i mean
tulip is very tulip is blonde
blue eyed and has really
big boobs
i am typecast i don't have any of this
and i think people were i was quite
surprised at people's sort of varmints
about their need to have
her um represented so
um accurately and
and because for me
that's the physicality i think that
for me it's about the spirit of a
character
um and i think that i can i think that
we retain that spirit we retain that
sort of um
misfit rebellious
um
anti-authority vulnerability um we just
made her look like me it's the only
difference
well that's actually a perfect segue to
the biography section of your resume and
retaining that spirit um because it does
seem both with shirley and then with
mildred loving that you obviously honor
the spirit of who those um
more public in the case of shirley
bassey and um hopefully iconically
uh famous now with with mildred but you
also bring a lot of yourself that this
is your interpretation your um
your translation of their spirit so
maybe just talking a little bit about um
shirley since that was she is so much
more of a public figure at this point
what you thought the challenge of kind
of bringing yourself and her spirit
together in that portrayal
um i i don't think i necessarily bring
myself to it because i i do i really
believe that
many people become actors to hide to
disappear and nice that's certainly the
case with me i just love this idea that
i could disappear into another world
another human being and i just found
that fascinating and
um
i i don't necessarily think of it like
bring i bring my own sort of
of course i bring myself because it's my
my body is my two and
whatnot but um
a lot of people have said in terms you
know of um playing mildred you know
you're not american
and that sort of baffles me because
i don't think
you need to be a certain
um belong to a certain person's um
country folk to play them it's because
if my job is to play the human being um
and play the spirit of them um to the
best possible way i can i mean i'm not
well shouldn't i play charlie um you
know that's my job is to be the
chameleon um
and i think if i if i if i am as
authentic
and truthful and
um
faithful to the human being as possible
um that's my only job to be honest with
you
but it was clear from the clip that we
saw and those of you seen shirley i mean
you
bring a power
that is certainly representative of
shirley bassey's power but
there's a sparkle of something from you
in there um and i'm just wondering is it
a moment for you to revel in that in
allowing that side of you that maybe
isn't always able to to come forward
yeah i think i think people i mean i'm
sure everyone's tired of hearing about
actors being shy but
i did it's a it's so many actors right
now are desperately shy and this is a
way that you can
um
you can
sort of be that person that peacock for
a while you know which is a lovely
feeling because i would you know even
though my like public speaking just
terrifies me i mean you can see i
haven't looked up in about
two hours um
um you know i mean i did a play uh play
once for the royal court with max server
clark called dark and and it was it was
a really long tour it was like eight
months and we opened in edinburgh and we
played the course we played the peacock
theatre in dublin and i had to be i had
to get undressed fully get in a bath
be in a bath for two scenes get out of
the bath dry myself put on clothes again
i'd often rather do that again for eight
months and
get on a stage and publicly talk as
myself
so yeah we are kind of shy
but it's very funny it's i don't know
it's it's a safe space to explore those
uh parts of yourself that you feel shy
about doing you know and i think that um
you it's this beautiful disappearance
and hiding and you can act out all those
things that you
have seen in those films and you know
and you see in performers you know who
are these chameleons and um
it's a very sort of it's something that
isn't unique to performers but it's
certainly not rare
um
but yeah it's this and it's not like i
don't i don't feel like i have those
moments in life it's just that um
it's a very lovely privilege to be able
to
just to pretend to be other people it
really is so let's then flip that and
talk about the the pressure of of
those interpreters the burden of
interpreting
uh public figures or in this case with
with mildred loving
historically you know
her significance is so profound and
the burden of interpreting that
character and and really living up to
people's expectations um and pressure
that you might feel
to to either honor that or create
something of your own that you know can
be judged on its own terms so if if you
feel that at all or if you're able to
just kind of let those expectations go
well i think often with characters and
you know especially mildred i don't i
didn't need to make my own mark i don't
feel that that's necessary because
if you if i don't know if you've seen
the nancy briskey documentary um the
loving story for hbo it's extraordinary
um
i only found out actually quite recently
i think it was a couple weeks ago that
we both
i'd known about the loving loving case
the love of west virginia case but i
hadn't really known about this couple
um we both in fact found out about
mildred um from her obituary
into that she does in 2008
and nancy was so profoundly affected by
her and what she'd achieved and so
um
so shocked actually and quite concerned
that um
she wasn't a fixture in our minds she
wasn't
she wasn't part of the canon the human
civil rights canon
and
she felt very strongly about that and so
she went looking for
mildred and richard and she couldn't
find them anywhere but she managed to
find this
documentary footage's archival footage
of this couple
that was meant to be turned into a
contemporary documentary but never was
and so she wove that in with this with
it with um other um contemporary footage
um and interviews with people from
central point and bowling green where
this couple are from i made this
beautiful documentary it's extraordinary
um
and that was the genesis of our film
essentially
and
when you watch this couple i mean as
human beings are extraordinary when you
watch them interact
it's like it's
whatever energy is between them is so
beautifully and beautiful and profound
and tangible their love for one another
um
it's deeply moving deeply
affecting
and
i fell in love with them immediately
just as everyone who watches this couple
did
and and you watched those moments in
this documentary that i'm jeff has
used to um
this woman was an extraordinary woman
there's nothing i needed to do to add to
her
she really came
came through this
the screen to me and
i fell profoundly in love with her she's
an extremist
embodies
um grace dignity humanity hope
humility
humor
kindness
bolstered by this
extraordinary strength
it's like there's a steel thread running
through her spine
and that wasn't
actually uncommon for many black women
that at that time because that's who
they had to be at that time for their
communities and um mildred is is
is is part of of of
that tradition um
and so i
i basically just needed to
be her become her and embody her which
was a responsibility and i was terrified
of us
but i think that you have to you have to
leave that tear at the door because i
didn't want anything to
impede
this did me playing her i didn't want
anything to paralyze me or
stop me from doing my job properly
something that i really admire that uh
you and jeff nichols the director and
joel your
your um
leading man in the film um did was
something you actually described earlier
which was make
the love story actually
kind of like uh-huh
right that you didn't fetishize
the fact that this was an interracial
couple it was
from the get-go something that was
beautiful and natural and right there
right in front of you
it the society around them you know
obviously had problems but there
that the fact that the choice was not
made to sensationalize i guess is what
i'm saying
that coupling was was brilliant and i
think is
very much about progress and is very
much about making this a contemporary
story where the kids who are watching it
today
might say yeah they're of course
they're in love because look at those
two gorgeous people so happy together
and then the shock of the society
rejecting that is what's so impactful
yeah i think i think the thing is is
that um
for jeff there and for this you know he
wants it to be clear that this wasn't
there they're being together and they're
getting married wasn't an act of
defiance
and i think that's a
that's that's
i think that hasn't changed people
aren't together
you know as a [ __ ] you to everybody
people are together because they're in
love
and i think it's really unfair of us to
go it must be because they feel it's an
act of defiance i think that's all
almost sort of diminishing
diminishing people's relationships
because
um
i think that's a very sort of a
rudimentary look at
at love actually uh let alone sort of
interracial love and
and couple mixed couples and
um and that was very important for jeff
because
they wanted to be together and i think
that jeff's
the line that just taken is
is that this couple did not want to be
in the limelight they had no desire to
be the face of civil rights
they
not that because they didn't agree is
because they were really shy they were
really reserved and they were from a
small rural town
um
in virginia and they simply all they
wanted was to raise their family
in their home and i think that jeff's
film exposes the folly of these laws
that were extremely corrosive
and obliterated families
and when you look into them they're
ridiculous they and they are ridiculous
and it exposes this kind of what fear
can do
fear and fear of what when you think
about it
um
and it's and it's it's
that was very important for us to um
to concentrate on
because this couple this ordinary couple
from
was according to everyone nowhere as
phil could do that she could scare the
establishment that much was
extraordinary
um
and eventually take it from court and
invalidate these horrible laws
um
and i think that's what people come out
of the cinema thinking you know
they did that that's extraordinary and
it wasn't because they were
um
they decided this is because
they fell in love but that was their
crime
and i think that's what shocks a lot of
people who didn't know that this only
happened 50 years ago
and i'm glad it shocks them because
shock
agitates you have a place of complacency
and that's what i think is necessary to
never let those things happen again
and to to recognize that
these things only happen when we're
complacent
um rambling again
look um i'm gonna get icky personal
right now there i had an ulterior motive
for really wanting to be a part of this
evening
and to get to meet you because um my
parents met in washington dc
in the mid 60s
my father is a dark-skinned indian man
an immigrant and my mother is a six foot
blonde the trophy every dark-skinned
indian man wants to win when he gets to
the states right
got her and they had to elope to florida
so in my mother's lifetime wow florida
you wouldn't think florida would you you
wouldn't think florida not today i mean
it wouldn't be the first place you think
of yeah
my mother's lifetime she couldn't marry
the man she loved in her home area
and now her son could marry whoever he
wants man or woman you know in this
country so i think the idea the
reaffirmation of progress is another
important element of the film yes
because we we can get cynical making it
because we all do and i think especially
now he will get so like really this is
this is what humanity is this is what
we're capable of really fear and
divisiveness so many people on that note
so many people have come up to us after
screenings and
said thank you for thank you for telling
our story thank you for telling my story
thank you for telling my parents story
thank you for bearing witness
because that to me is the most one of
the most important things we can do is
bear witness to stories because so often
we forget
and when we forget
something happens
we i think we it's so easy to go
backwards
um
and it's there's so many people and for
me as well that's really important
because i'm a mixed-race kid
and you forget that this is
this is part of what i was talking about
earlier is seeing our stories
represented
um and i think that i do think that this
film really does resonate with a lot of
people not just people like you and i
but people who
um hadn't even heard that this was
illegal ever
um that you know and i think that
and people are horrified and shocked and
you know and it's it's not about feeling
guilty and it's not about this being
this is another thing it's not this
isn't just a story for people like you
know it's not a story for just the black
community this is america's story you
know and i always feel like this is
these stories aren't just for oh the
people that this happened to it's for
it's for all of us you know this is
humanity's story i mean this is the
world story
um and then it's brilliant that you know
this this richard mildred are
representing that because they represent
america
and i do think that when americans find
out about this couple they're really
extremely proud of them
um and i'm i'm proud of them and
i'm just you know a small person from
ireland and ethiopia
so as a last question then assuming the
world everything's right with the world
and you know and it always is the doors
are about to swing wide open for you um
what's something a role a character
um
a job
a new frontier that you would like to
cross um
i'm a tourist so i don't like new
frontiers
um
i think you know i don't know i'm not a
planner it just it makes me nervous also
it doesn't really suit
the life of an actor
at all um
i really i like i love i love i love i
love doing preacher i love it and i
loved doing loving working with jeff
nichols so if i could just do
preacher and a jack nichols film once a
year i'm ground
well let's plan on lots more of those
ruth [ __ ] everyone
thank you thank you for having me thank
you thank you
you